this movie has a lot of singing
I would like to sing this whole review
do not fret yourself I'm only kidding
then click on subscribe' lame is Rob is
directed by Tom Hooper and has a
fantastic ensemble cast including Hugh
Jackman Russell Crowe and Hathaway Sacha
Baron Cohen Amanda Seyfried Helena
Bonham Carter lots of people in this
movie and this is definitely a musical
my friends in fact in regards to the
dialogue in this film
it's almost probably 95% through song
and whenever there is another little
word that may not be through song it's
usually broken in the middle of a song
where someone will be like oh and then
just bring be like so how are you doing
today all I am doing just fine tells the
tale of a man who was once imprisoned
Hugh Jackman who agrees to take care of
a young girl and the troubles that come
from that as he is hunted by a Russell
Crowe's character all the while the
French Revolution is going on in the
background as these characters grow
older war persists even more people fall
in love people are hunted all different
types of things happen now I'm not the
biggest fan of musicals my thing is if
they're good they're good and I will
respect them for that but there are a
lot of musicals out there that are not
good I think one of the biggest failures
you can make in a film is not be a good
musical because then everyone in it
looks like an absolute idiot gratefully
that is not the case here I thoroughly
enjoyed Leigh miserab I was very
impressed with this film it is extremely
long it's like a hundred and fifty seven
minutes it is very ambitious in regards
to the sets the special effects the
performances obviously have to be
fantastic and there are two that are so
so good in this film in particular but
everyone does a pretty good job I feel
but Hugh Jackman and Anne Hathaway are
definitely the standouts of this film
the thing to me that is most impressive
about this movie is the fact that they
sang live on set this is not
pre-recorded or studio versions of you
know there
lip-syncing to their own voices they
sang live on set and you can see it in
their faces
when characters are observing themselves
physically or crying you can hear it in
their voices how their voice changes
based on what's actually happening on
set in that moment what was captured in
camera I am so impressed by that and it
made this film reach a different level
that it would not have reached if the
audio was pre-recorded the film looks
incredibly beautiful Tom Hooper likes to
frame people like with their heads in
the bottom corner and have all this
space up here he did that a lot in The
King's Speech he does that a lot here at
times it was a little distracting but
for the most part I think the film looks
very beautiful
and one of the things I really liked
about the way he cut this movie together
was for some of the more intense songs
or the more intense dramatic
performances he would just leave it at
one angle the entire time for like a
good three minutes without cutting and I
really like that because it captured a
raw performance that you wouldn't have
been able to manufacture with cutting it
up and I really enjoyed that about this
movie overall this is a really good
musical and coming from someone who
isn't the biggest fan of them if you
love musicals or if you were really like
pumped to see this movie because I was
just like I'm gonna go see this movie
and I hope it's good but if you were
really pumped for this movie or you love
musicals you are going to poop this
movie is going to make you poop and
you're gonna have it just it's you're
gonna love it I did have a couple issues
with the movie and I think my biggest
one is definitely the time it's a long
one my friends 2 hours and 40 minutes of
pretty much just singing unless it's a
band that you are just so pumped out of
your mind to see can get a little
tedious towards the end it is a little
too long in my opinion there are times
when I was like do we really need this
musical number here I mean let's get to
the more meteor part of the story and I
think my main issue with the film is a
bit of a spoiler so I can't really say
it so I'll try to find a way around
saying it my favorite aspect of this
film is the first act I was blown away
by the sheer dramatic power of this film
thus as the film concluded that was
maintained because certain aspects that
were in the first act returned for the
final act I really loved that first act
and I was thinking holy crap I hope the
rest of the film is like this certain
story is worn as energy
as others as the first-act concluded but
I still thoroughly enjoyed this film as
a musical
it has great musical numbers fantastic
acting on Hugh Jackman Spartan and
Hathaway I think they're both
oscar-worthy for the time that they
spent in this film a lot of people have
mentioned Russell Crowe as not the
greatest singer and yes if you stack him
up compared to these two people Hugh
Jackman and Anne Hathaway he doesn't
stack up to the other guys he's not as
good he does have his own band you know
he does sing and perform on stage live
I love the Simon Cowell type I'm not
very good at judging singers as much as
others I think he did fine and maybe his
singing wasn't as good as Hugh Jackman's
and Anne Hathaway but his performance
that he gave along with the singing I
thought was very good I'm gonna give
lame as Rob a B+ it's a very good
musical if you like musicals you're
gonna love it I'm not the biggest fan so
me just saying that that's pretty
awesome for me to give it a rating like
that
thanks a lot as always for watching guys
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]